Pierre McGuire is a busy man NBC Sports
Emmy award-winning inside the glass
analyst and exclusive coverage of the
Stanley Cup final continues Thursday
night at 8:00 Eastern on NBC from Las
Vegas with Game five with the caps on
the verge of the cup Pierre thanks for
joining us recap last night if you will
Dan first of all I'm never too busy to
visit with you and I want to apologize
in advance they'll be some background
noise I'm gay g21 at the Minneapolis st.
Paul Airport so you'll hear some Delta
that's the folks announcing takeoffs and
landings that being said divine
intervention played a role in last
night's game
starpower played a role in last night's
game for the Washington Capitals
physicality played a role in the outcome
of the game last night but more than
anything else I think the ability of
Washington to sustain quick-strike
offense and it carried over from Game
three the game for that's been a huge
factor and the game breakers have been
Afghani Kuznetsov and Alexander Ovechkin
is the better team winning the deeper
team is winning right now Ben I don't
know if they're the better team yet they
probably will be at some point but
they're the deeper team and part of
their depth is down the middle when you
look at Nicklas Backstrom and you look
at the beginning Cruz and that's off you
look at Lars Eller and you look at Jay
Beagle I don't know Vegas has enough to
match up but down the middle with that
foursome and that makes it really a
difficult game to play when did this
series turn great question I would say
in the Braden Holtby save against Alex
talked at the tail end of Game two if if
that putt goes in there's so much
enthusiasm and momentum in the series
for Vegas they're probably going into
overtime and that potentially win who
know they can't tell you but that was a
series momentum swinging save and you
could see that Washington built off that
you know down I'm not a big fan that you
can bring momentum from game to game to
game you know in the playoffs in hockey
but what I do believe you can do is you
can bring moments from game to game to
game and the moment that will resonate
is the safe by hopefully against talking
game - we like our superstars our old
time greats to win champions
I mean that's how we validate greatness
you move up the list you move down the
list in accordance to how many titles
what does this do if he wins a title for
alex ovechkin and how he's viewed
historically this will solidify his
reputation as one of the greatest goal
scorers in the history of the National
Hockey League even those numbers would
tell you he's already bad he's got over
600 goals in 13 years in the league
which is phenomenal
he's never scored fewer than 32 goals in
any one season he had 49 this year Dan I
mean the numbers don't lie on him but
what this does if we're were to happen
it would definitely point him in the
direction of one of the greatest goal
scorers in the history game now I'll
give you a list of some guys that are in
the Hockey Hall of Fame like rod Jill
bear who's a legend John Russell who's a
legend they never won the Stanley Cup
and you can look at the modern era Paul
Kariya was in the last Hall of Fame
class not never won a Stanley Cup so you
know they're guys that are in the Hockey
Hall of Fame that didn't need the cup to
solidify the reputation well what this
would do for Ovechkin would solidify I
think his stature it's a lot of greatest
goal scorers make sure the game it would
be your top five you know can you do
players or if I just said Gold scores
are you just gonna run down the list of
those who have the most goals I'd rather
do players I think it's probably better
that way
you know I would start with Bobby Orr
and Wayne Gretzky and Mario Lemieux and
Gordie Howe and then it's after that
it's open to debate
but I would say those would probably be
your preeminent most people would say
that has been around the league making a
living at it
that those would probably be the best
players of all time it bother you are
totally revolutionized and changed how
the game was played with offense from
the defense Wayne Gretzky I don't think
anybody can argue with his greatness
Mario Lemieux had he not you know been
stricken with cancer and back ailments
who knows you know what kind of numbers
he would have put up and Gordie Howe you
know I've missed her go late Gordy al
but mr. hockey to everybody that you
know knew him just an unbelievable
talent what do you think the Golden
Knights success will mean for other
sports going in there I know the Raiders
are going in there can you see this
being you know opening up even wider
where
NBA or a baseball team ends up in Las
Vegas hard for me to speak about the
other sports because I just don't know
what their mentalities will be going
forward obviously I think you've been
talking about it a fair bit to Dan is
the legalizing of gambling on sports
teams I think that could really change a
lot of what's going to happen in the
whole sports universe so I think that's
something to watch I really can't speak
for the other sports I don't know them
intimately enough in terms of their
decision-making but I can tell you this
it's worked magnificently well with
hockey that fanbase is electrifying then
it is one of the best hockey experiences
you can ever have and you talk about
friendly knowledgeable and in just
excitable fans they have it and it's
just a fantastic market and you know
everybody bill Foley deserves a lot of
credit but so did the Maloof brothers
who are part owner to that team they
really understand the Vegas landscape
and I think they've done a magnificent
job having the team galvanized with the
community especially after the terrible
shooting tragedy before the season
started have you had one of those
moments those in game interviews behind
the glass like it was awkward only what
I'm talking to you I'm joking no you
know we haven't had any John Tortorella
moments no everything's been great berry
trots has been fantastic jargon has been
great to deal with the players on both
teams have been excellent I think
probably the funniest one was Afghani
Kuznets off after he scored the overtime
winner against Pittsburgh and they had
already they knocked Pittsburgh out and
I said some were you worried about going
home he goes no my wife was on vacation
recap the Tortorella story John just
didn't want to be that you know what I
love his press conferences it's must-see
TV for me when towards you know because
but if you ask him a question you're
gonna get an answer depending on his
mood
yeah that's exactly right it's a good
thing sometimes we have them on tape
because curse words it wouldn't always
work out - oh he's a character ma'am
hey safe travels up here and thanks for
joining us have fun Thursday night
thanks so much Dan I really appreciate
it fantastic visiting me man thanks for
supporting hockey ban it means a lot
thank you buddy that's pure McGuire NBC
Sports Emmy award-winning inside the
glassed analyst for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]